a full-blown civil war breaking out
among democrats now that joe biden's
bill back better is a dud at least for
this year socialists bernie sanders
blasting moderate democrats joe manchin
and kirsten cinema for not doing exactly
as progressive want
and you got two people who say you know
what hey if you don't do it my way i
don't care what the president wants i
don't care what 48 of my colleagues want
it's my way or the highway and that i
regard as arrogance you can disagree
look i have disagreements as you well
know all right you fight for your ideas
but you don't say my way or the highway
democrats also bickering over the
direction that the party needs to take
to avoid a wipeout in the midterms but
despite the dysfunction democrats are
still trying to claim joe's doing a
great job
this is the first year of the biden
administration and we have passed huge
pieces of their legislative agenda
frankly they dwarf the first-year
accomplishments of many other
administrations it's been a year of real
substantive progress
inflation running at a 40-year high well
done
they're getting crushed by inflation
their voters are getting crushed by
inflation but all they care about is
january 6. until they wake up to how
dangerous inflation is they're just
totally hopeless it's funny to hear
bernie complain about people being a
problem in the senate ask obama what he
thought about bernie when obama was
president he hated bernie he was a pain
in the butt and so you have mansion
who's at what 60 approval right now in
west virginia state trump won by 40
points he's not going to go and be like
the last vote to kill cole to destroy
the dollar to destroy voter right he's
not going to do that he's dug in and
cinema is in the 40s she's loved by
independents and republicans there
that's a state that puts out really
liberal republicans flake mccain she's
like a conservative democrat so she's
right in that sweet spot there in that
state so she's fine
democrats complaining about mavericks
welcome to the republican party you got
like 10 senators that are always joining
the democrats on infrastructure debt
healthcare i mean welcome to my world
yeah i mean everything so enough they're
going into a midterm year with only two
things they got covered relief people
don't feel very relieved about that in
an infrastructure build it you're not
going to see a project finished for at
least a decade so they got nothing
they have a 50-50 senate maisie hirono
richard yesterday the senator said 50-50
senate sucks
well you know what sucks more for the
democrats if it's 51-49 when joe manchin
turns republican during an election year
well i don't think joe man is going to
turn republican but i i mean i do i
actually agree with jesse on this
particular point i've done so we've done
some reporting around how
people in the democratic base feel about
the party specifically african-american
voters and african-american voters are
very dissatisfied with where the party
is one they don't feel like the party's
talking to them or providing the
adequate messaging but two and more
importantly i don't think they believe
that their party is listening to them
right i think the part is saying to a
lot of other people but they're not
listening to african-americans i thought
you saw that this week when the
president came out and sort of announced
that student loan repayment is going to
start again that was to the chagrin of a
lot of african-americans when the
president made a commitment during the
election that he was going to forgive
ten thousand student loan debt and now
he's saying well no you have to repay
and i think there's a lot of folks out
here not only african-americans but
other voters millennial voters as well
saying come on joe we voted for you and
now you have to at least give us
something so that we can turn back out
for you in the midterms if the
democratic party does not begin to have
a conversation with its base soon the
midterms can be more worse than it
already seems it's going to be great
yeah i don't think that i don't think it
was about the student loans it's about
the crime blacks and hispanics are
pissed off because they're being ignored
because they're living in the na the
they're living in the neighborhoods that
are deeply affected by this this crime
wave just uh what you mentioned the
mavericks let's not forget that all
these people complaining really love
john mccain woody torpedo when he did
this with his hand remember how that was
everywhere
well now that's happening
uh
the big failure here is joe was supposed
to supply some kind of genial calm he
was supposed to be some like uh
comfy
old sweater after the biker jacket that
was trump but now he's like a corset
made of wasps
it's like it's safe to say he might have
the first
the worst first year of any president he
won basically wandered through 2021 like
he does in the white house garden when
he's trying to look for an entrance he's
left a trail of chaos master denial
blissfully unaware that the country is
suffering and i go back to that just the
one the the most important the most
important thing in my head is the crime
because it's visual it's immediate
everybody knows somebody that's been a
victim and some many of us have been
victims so i think that right now they
if they got to do something big or
they're going to get destroyed for a
long time
and you've got bernie from the nut land
of ben and jerry's talking about
arrogance well
i don't know since when is voting your
conscience and for your constituency
arrogant the president i don't know who
these people are
but this is disgusting
two people holding the country hostage
this is not what america wants america
wants socialism uh that's he thinks that
and all like socialism is based on
arrogance it is based on the idea that
you know we the few technocrats will
decide
what to do for you for the rest of your
life we will create an entire nation of
victims so we can solve all of your
problems but it's not problem solving it
is control it is taking your money
through high taxes and then creating
systems and all sorts of entitlements
that make you beholden to the government
in every aspect of your life regardless
of what normal rational people think
that is the arrogance of socialism
shouting your point constantly to make
it seem like your loudness equals a
large base it does not and that's why
the president and the vice president and
congress have horrible ratings right now
because people have woken up to that
they don't want their money stolen from
them so the government can tell them
what to do in every single area of their
life it is utter arrogance and of course
he knows something about that because
he's been steeped in the socialism his
entire life bernie went on his honeymoon
to the soviet union he's not even a good
socialist he's got like kind of a
craptastic lake house yes
my only point here is this and i hear
your argument my and i agree that the
president does have low approval writing
but i think if you look at the things
that are in buildback better whether it
be helping families deal with child care
whether you're making sure that people
who are on medicaid or medicare talk
about the child tax credit no wait a
minute hold on whether it be oh yeah
getting hearing aids one year and then
or glasses for senior citizens these are
all popular things right it's all these
are all popular members maybe we could
afford to give glasses to senior
citizens if we weren't raping the
economy uh with these arbitrary climate
mandates there aren't climate minutes
to greg's corset made of wasps
and lace it up tight richard
to greg's point public safety it is
public safety and where have they failed
border afghanistan couldn't keep our
soldiers safe a crime and then they look
at the american people and lie about it
what you're seeing it's not happening
you know those border agents uh within
immigrants lie after lie afterwards it
pisses people off at it
they were pissed because they
where's the investigation they tabled it
because it didn't happen hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else